الجديد باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل
القاعده العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه
مروي هذا هو برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده
وللمطار هذا البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في
هذه النقطه وقد عاكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق
به الان سنحاول ان نقترب اكثر عبر هذا
البث الحصري لقناه العربيه لمعرفه تفاصيل
ما حدث وحجم الضرر الذي لحق بهذا الجزء من
المطار وبالقاعده العسكريه العملياتيه
هذا الامر الان كما نتابع الان حجم للضرر
في هذه القاعده نحن الان سنقترب اكثر
نحن الان نصعد الى الدرجات العليا لهذا
البرج
وهو برج المراقبه الرئيس لهذا المطار الذي
يمتد لي عدد من الطوابق
كثير من الاضرار لاحقت بهذا البرج الذي
يعول عليه كثيرا في العمليات الملاحيه
الجويه
هذا البرج خالد خلال الايام الماضيه كان
تحت محطه النيران نتيجه للاشتباكات التي
كانت متواصله في هذا الجزء
وفي هذه المنطقه
من القاعده العسكريه كل الصور الان التي
تشاهدها هي من داخل هذا البرج
نحن الان في مناطق عليا
من هذا البرج
الذي تضرر بحسب حفاادات خاصه
لمدير المطار والان نشاهد
هذه هي بعض الطلقات
الناريه او الطلقات
الاسلحه هذا الضرر لهذا البرج
تشاهد الان
ايضا حجم الضرر في هذه المناطق
وصل اليها هذا البرج
ضرر كثير لحقت بالاجهزه هذه بعض الاجهزه
الفنيه التي تستخدم هنا في اطار العمليات
الملاحيه الجويه
ايضا تاثرت
محاول ايضا ان نصعد اكثر
لمعرفه التفاصيل
واستجلاء المعلومه عن حجم الضرر عبر الصوت
والصوره وعبر البث الحي
ما زلنا داخل برج
المراقبه هذه اجهزه فنيه
اخبرونا انها
على درجه عاليه من الحساسيه
اجهزه تقنيه
ايضا تاثرت وتضررت
كما تشاهدون الان في هذه الصور
الخاصه لقناه العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات